you said I saw your tweet you got a 90
day fiancé oh yeah it's gotta get to the
guy with no neck oh yeah the little uh I
think you should Filipino being it his
spine isn't sprouted that's what
happened if you look at it yes head just
yeah just everything hasn't sprouted you
know he's like it that little spud yeah
I bet if you tickle him hard enough dude
where I grew up that a lot people that
would tickle you really [ __ ] hard dog
make you grow a couple inch Oh brah make
you [ __ ] make your head want to pop
off your body what's his name huh what
again is that big n that's that little
guy yeah yeah it was good man I'm at the
part right now where dude there's so
much going only great oh I mean the
white girl with the rapper Soulja Boy oh
yeah soldier boy yeah he says a music
video he's not that bad no he's not
Betty well he's the best guy in South
Africa yeah and then or the Congo I
think Nigeria that's right so it was a
short I got there he has the music video
haha any other he has a sob in it on his
girl gets pissed I'm gonna watch this
right now it's called before the 90-day
fiance
yeah so I haven't seen any of it until
now and it's just alarming man it makes
you gives you hope huh I don't know they
can do it you can do it
yeah that's your head with no neck I
found the girl in the Philippines Theo
can do it dude yeah there he is right
there God he's handsome dude hell yeah
hey how about so she doesn't shave her
legs and they have sex for the first
time and he's like listen you gotta
shave your legs when I keep doing this
and she gets all pissed she's like I'll
do it if you shave your beard she has
that boy shave his beard huh just when
you didn't think I could get any uglier
really this boy you think he's handsome
dude where I'm from he's handsome he's
at least a frickin sick that makes sense
he's a he's a solid one from there he's
straight thanks bro Luke please you can
sell you some fake diamonds
on a scale of one to ten easy we should
get him on this past weekend if Nick
would [ __ ] do his job dude makes you
busy finding decent players from [ __ ]
the stage a hog
I got a Clay Matthews Jersey it's
starting to get white that's where you
know it's getting bad Aaron Rodgers I
know you got it Aaron Rodgers you got a
you got a Reggie White those are all the
Emperor jerseys I got a Melvin Gordon
Wisconsin native t-shirt t-shirt Jersey
no word but yeah they have a lot of
money you should get that Mitchell and
no longer edition they got Reggie White
who else who else wears the r.i.p
jerseys man they got that you can get a
Jerome Brown from that Mitchell and
Asness really that Nestle that Mitchell
Nestle's room brandade had the big ad
yeah hey bring up bring up the white
girl who's made in the black doors
marrying the black guy the black guys
definitely managed all of that green
coming Lisa oh yeah yeah good job dude
and if you gonna say Lisa a fiancee I
thought about it dude that little
thought I would do 9 day fiancé I could
decide in 9 days I feel like me what the
hell's he doing with her I made 90 days
with her I felt he was a roller Hertz
wrong with her man that nice
good-looking gentleman he gonna roll
with that what do you got crawl through
some [ __ ] to get to America oh you gotta
also decide your sexuality voice our
judge in the picture dude obviously the
lady is way a dime compared to him
because he's a man okay so if a you if
you're interested in women then you're
gonna be more interested for her then
you are the guy right unless is
drug-induced
your mouth rolling around dude it is
gonna be nice right all no Fiona we
can't overlook that he said Method Man 1
plus 1 equals [ __ ] uh sold yeah boy
oh and that and then there's that one
older dude who's going after the Russian
and she's gone ma I am ia like seven
times on him and he keeps going to
Russia searching for it oh yeah that's
right Matt right now and he's just going
her way she never shows up she [ __ ] dude
give it up
what it's 90 day fiancé
yeah it was gonna be chaos now it's not
what do you think you to do show up on
the 8th time well I mean I think you
give somebody four or five chances right
okay you give somebody some
international chances Brendon you're an
idiot that's fair well if you traveled
if you have if you hadn't canceled all
your European dates like you did why
have you because a corona yeah if you
were [ __ ] not a legend you have to
says the guy who canceled shows in brain
got a cold sorry you wanna do this I've
been there full weekend the worst driver
I've ever seen yeah dude I'm not even
joking here still had a sore knee and
cancel this sold-out shows in brain yeah
bro happy dude tell me for 17 years
Miley's sold-out brand had a kink in his
neck and cancelled the show is for brain
doesn't have an aneurysm hole because
how do I wanna apologize organising the
brain I would T like to apologize for
you guys but I would like to say this
that Brendan if you'll pull him up Nick
if you didn't just quit your job if you
pull up Brendan he looks like long end
if you have big a head and long hair and
you put them right next to each other
did you know whose y'all harder to do
that you know anybody already do that
you know he should get with is the girls
from thousand-pound sisters really
that's it
have you seen that show Oh living
thousand-pound sisters dude let's go to
our urban connoisseur right here chubby
chicks uh no really can't say that cuz
the one she's she's so thick
she's will she's a thickest person I've
ever seen she has fat on her forehead
oh wow yeah it's like growing out of
here what I think roll baby dick you're
not you're not into fat chicks either no
one's into chubby cheese you guys that
think roll PJ right up above her
eyebrows I can't say I've never been if
you don't think Nick has been into a
thick look at the kind of guy will take
a gun and put a little and just shoot it
on the ground near a woman yeah see she
bites burning I'm telling you look I'm
long eared bro I'm telling you bro if
you tickled it a little bit or bigad
hard enough dude it would be you but a
hairstyles brother yeah you think about
this dude I will say this about big
ant-man he's extremely charming oh well
I do notice this though it seemed like
he's very chatty chatty and sweats a lot
oh the dangerous combo do you tell the
chicks not into him and we got have you
got there he gay no I haven't gotten far
I don't know where you're at dude huh
the show's been going on for months has
it yeah I just got a new it last night I
was I got in I saw Michael Rapaport up
at 2:00 a.m. screaming about Donald
Trump on Twitter hey switch it up switch
it up it is correct by commercial
dropping rapid him yell yeah also rap
get off the truck dude switch up your
material for God dude I'll tell you this
micro rapid work just because I
I'm gonna vote for Donald Trump now
because he led me to it yeah this is
your doing wrong it has nothing to do
with him dude it's all because of you
bro do it because of you
[Music]
the king
[Music]